ضربه مصدره الواقع وغربيه الرياض مسار تم
عمله من قبل جمعيه درب يهدف الى تطوير
ثقافه المشي والهايكنج حسب له طوله هذا
المسار حوالي عاشت كيلومترات ذهابا وايابا
يبدا بمنطقه ترابيه ويمتد الى منطقه
الصخور البركانيه والدوائر الحجريه التي
يبلغ عمرها الاف السنين الان هالحين خمس
مسارات انتهينا منها المخطط حل يعني خلال
الشهر هذا ان شاء الله هنخلص كمان اربع
مسارات فهيكون خلالها السنه هذه 9 مسارات
تنتهينا منها السنه الجايه ان شاء الله
خطتنا هيكون فيها حوالي 40 مسار خلال خمس
سنين احنا ناويين ندبل المسارات كل سنه
يعني حلمنا ان نوصل الى الف مساء خلال خمس
سنين ينتهي المساره بالوصول الى جبل صغير
يضم واحده من اضخم الوجهات الصخريه
المغطاه بفنون النحت الصخري تعود الى
ثمانيه الى في سنه وتنفرد باشكال نادره
لانواع الحيوانات التي كانت تعيش في تلك
المنطقه
هذه اللي خلف قناتها تتكون من 210 رسم
صخري وهي تعتبر من اكبر الواجهات في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه طبعا عندنا مثل
ما ذكرنا له 15 واجهه صخريه في الموقع
شرقيه وغربيه وجنوبيه وشماليه
وعمره اقدم رسم موجود في هذه المنطقه همم
يعود الى زمن ما يقارب 6000 سنه قبل
الميلاد يعني ما يقارب ثمانيه الاف سنه من
العراق
بانشاء هذا المسار وتهيئته ليكون مسارا
واضحا يسهل للجميع ارتياده والمشي فيه
وذلك لجلب الانتباه لمنطقه سيقرا والتعرف
على المزيد من المعالم السياحيه
والتاريخيه
ممارس الهايكنج يجمع بين الرياضه والتعايش
مع الطبيعه في واحد من الرياضات التي باتت
منتشره على نطاق واسعا في السعوديه بين
مختلف الفئات العمريه ويعدها البعض فرصه
لتعريف بالمعالم السياحيه
والاثريه والتضاريس المتنوعه في البلاد
غدا الفهد العربيه الرياض